as an inquisitive and interpretive
species we are always working to examine
critique and improve the world around us
we want what's best for the world and we
all like to believe that we know what's
best for it as a result we constantly
judge and critique the things we
encounter in life including other people
this innate competitive self-confidence
is well intended but it often results in
a pessimistic judgment of other people
what we must understand is that there
are two sides to the coin of
self-confidence on one side it is good
to have a unique perspective of the
world that we believe in and work for
but on the other side we must not take
it so far as to let it become negative
and limiting progression revelation and
wonder cultivate outside of our bubbles
of ideology and if our
self-righteousness
is too rigid we close ourselves off from
such opportunity we must balance both
sides and free ourselves of rigid
self-righteousness we must remind
ourselves that just as valuable as our
views and ideals are to us so our other
views and ideals to other people if we
do not want others to discard and
belittle the ways in which we live we
must ensure that we are not discarding
or belittling the way in which others
live we must work to develop and improve
our sense of the world through open
mindedness we must utilize our unique
human capacity for empathy
when you focus on empathy you understand
that just as others are imperfect so are
you when you admit this you balance
judgment out and neutralize its harmful
effects you no longer feel as though you
are above anyone and as a result no
longer feel as though you are beneath
anyone in reducing your degree of
self-righteousness you reduce irrational
and unnecessary negativity in your life
in its place forms a heightened openness
and opportunity to learn experience and
connect you become open to life and life
becomes open to you
thank you for watching if you found
enjoyment and value in this video please
give it a thumbs up share your thoughts
in the comments below and if you are not
already be sure to subscribe to our
Channel we are constantly coming out
with new videos to help you experience
life with clarity and Wonder